hey everyone and welcome back uh hope
you're all glad to be here as you can
see I've changed my camera angle ever so
slightly because I've gone ahead and
switched up my desk setup it's actually
looking decently clean now I may have to
go ahead and show that off in a future
video but as you can see we are getting
pretty close to the end of this system's
design concept series and so right now
I'm currently looking at the light at
the end of the tunnel I mean besides
this I've got a couple of short rant
videos I want to make and then a couple
of collaborations and then soon we're
going to be on to those interview
questions so hope you guys are looking
forward to it let's start talking about
caching okay so as I previously
mentioned today we would be talking
about caching so if you remember from
your operating systems class here is
effectively what a CPU looks like we've
got all of our cores over here as you
can see this will be a two core CPU and
then we've got a few layers of cash
until eventually we reach memory and
then finally we get to our slowest form
of storage which is going to be disk now
for something like a CPU again the whole
point is we have this hierarchy of cash
and cash enables us to do a lot of
things but the biggest thing it's going
to enable us to do is do faster reads
and faster writes and possibly even
Shield some accesses to slower forms of
data like memory and disk and in
distributed systems we basically are
doing the same thing so let's go talk
about some actual benefits of caching in
distributed systems specifically as I
resize my screen
so number one is that typically your
reads and rights should be faster when
using a cache the reason being that
you're probably going to be using a
faster form of storage so in this case
we've got memory which we'll probably be
using as opposed to disk additionally
we might end up saving ourselves quite a
few Network calls so as you can see that
would be over here where we would reach
out to our server which may have an
actual cache built into the actual
computer itself and as a result we
wouldn't have to reach out to the DB
again thus saving us some time and then
finally another nice thing about caching
potentially is that we can place the
cache physically closer to our client
thus saving us time because you know the
internet packets have to travel less
distance additionally caching can also
help us reduce our load on certain key
components so for example over here if
we have one single database node and a
lot of different clients that are trying
to reach out to it if all of those
clients are asking for the same piece of
data for example if they all want to see
their home feed and all of their home
feeds are the same having one single
larger caching layer which can answer
most of those requests is going to allow
our database to do more important
computations that are unique
so I've gone over the benefits of
caching but of course just like
everything else in systems design there
are trade-offs and so what are the
drawbacks that we experience well for
one cache misses are super expensive
they're going to slow us down quite
considerably so as you can see we've got
a client over here not only is this
cache Miss physically going to have to
make a network call to get to the cache
but also depending on the type of actual
implementation that we use for our cache
storage actually searching for a key
within the cache could be linear time it
could be logarithmic time ideally it
would be constant time but that's not
always the case and so then only after
we miss in our cache will we go ahead
and reach out to the database thus
wasting time another thing is that data
consistency is complex mainly for
example if we've got two clients and
they're both trying to read from their
respective cache these caches might have
different values and this is of course a
problem that we've seen all throughout
distributed systems for example when we
have multiple different replicas of the
database we often have to deal with
stale data and that can be problematic
now of course this does depend on how
much you care if again you're like fine
I'm okay with eventual consistency I'm
okay with still data or possibly even
incorrect data then of course caching is
not going to be as detrimental to your
system but either way it does still add
quite a bit of complexity
okay so the next question that we're
actually going to quickly attempt to
answer is what do we cash and this one
should be pretty simple if you start to
think about it but the gist is any form
of computation or anything that could be
remotely expensive to do or load or read
so that could be database results you
know if we have a big query to a table
and we know that we're going to be
reusing that many times over that would
be great to Cache another thing is
computations done by application servers
for example sometimes a database can
give you partial results but you either
want to merge that with some other
results that you have perform some
subsequent computations or anything like
that and so actually performing a
caching of the results of what was on
the server can be very useful as well
and then also just like popular static
content that could be images it could be
web page files anything like that we're
going to devote an entire video to that
topic alone when we talk about cdns okay
so now I'm going to dub a term called
server local caching because now that
we've answered the question what do we
cache we should probably start talking
about where do we store it so one type
of kind of storing uh this data I would
call server local just made it up so you
know don't quote me on that don't use it
in a systems design interview but the
point is the data that you're caching
can actually be stored on the
application servers themselves and when
I say application server that could mean
many different types of things it could
be a database like this guy over here it
could be a message broker if you're
reading the same message over and over
and over again for example in Kafka it
could also be on your application
servers or zookeeper your coordination
service anything like that so what would
be an example of this let's imagine
we're looking at Tinder over here and I
like the dirty dog that I am keep going
back to my page to check who's liked me
well I'm going to probably run that
query pretty often and it's probably not
going to be updating very often right
it's probably infrequent that I get
likes as many of them as I do have
because I'm a handsome devil they don't
come in that frequently so as a result
if I'm checking them every single five
minutes they're mostly going to stay the
same so rather than having to reach out
to the database and do an extra Network
call
what we can actually do instead is go
ahead and just get it right from the
application server after it's been
returned for the first time and so you
may notice here that when we have
multiple application servers it's very
important that I am going to be reaching
out to the same application server every
single time now we've spoken about
consistent hashing in the past in this
series but this is also something that's
very important in load balancing if I'm
a client and I'm going to reach out to
one of my application servers it's very
important that I'm going to the same
server every single time specifically so
that I can reach the server that is
actually cache the data specific to me
that is why something like consistent
hashing
seems I already wrote it out so that was
kind of redundant but the point is if
you recall it's basically a ring that
splits up all of the traffic and you
know it tells you where you're going to
be routed to the reason being that
consistent hashing as opposed to just
like random routing is going to maximize
our cash hits
you can watch the consistent hashing
video if you're a little unclear on how
that might work but let's actually
quickly before I move on to the next
picture go into some pros and cons the
pros of doing server local caching or
you know just keeping your cash local to
the application server is there fewer
Network calls like I mentioned you're
already going to be hitting this thing
anyway so you may as well check the cash
that makes it faster but on the other
hand well if this guy were to go down
that cash for me is gone and
additionally let's say we wanted even
more caches because not only do we want
to cash you know all the people who've
liked me but we also want to cash let's
say uh all of their photos and and
certain other information about them so
it turns out we need more cash storage
than we thought well the issue in this
case is that we're limited by basically
the number of application servers that
we have because that's where we're
storing the data but it would be nice if
we could scale that cache independently
which leads us to our second possible
implementation of caching which is using
a global caching layer so as you can see
that caching layer would be this guy
right here and when you hit an
application server it could potentially
reach out to any of those caches which
is good because it means that you don't
necessarily have to rely on consistent
hashing as much to hit a certain
application server it might mean that I
could hit any of these but technically
if you know my data was only stored on
one of these nodes then we would
probably need a second load balancer
right here to make sure that we were
hitting that particular cache anyways
let's quickly talk about the pros and
cons of something like this the biggest
Pro of course is going to be that we can
scale it as we need we're not basically
Locked Down based on the number of
application servers that we have this
layer can scale on its own the biggest
con of course is that basically our
cache is no longer local to the
application server so now we have to
make an extra Network call in order to
access that data which could definitely
be expensive additionally we now just
have more moving Parts in our system
which means more things can fail we have
to think about fault tolerance a little
bit more and of course practically
speaking sometimes that is not very good
so let's quickly do a conclusion so that
I can go ahead and go to sleep but
basically caches are going to seriously
allow us to get much better latencies
within both of our reads and our rights
the reason being that typically they'll
use a faster form of storage than the
kind of naive disk implementation that
we use with our databases additionally
we can put them literally just closer to
us and that helps a lot speed things up
because you know
just less distance for those packets to
travel like I mentioned before another
thing is that we can effectively
establish a wall in front of other
components that are a bit more
performance critical if I'm making the
same request 10 times over there's no
reason the database has to answer it 10
times over because it's going to
re-perform a bunch of computations but
at the same time introducing a cache to
our system has some caveats of course
cache misses are really bad and also we
may have some data consistency issues if
it's important to us if for example I
you know one cache knows what my
password is but I go ahead and change my
password and the cache doesn't realize
that and I keep entering my change
password and the the cache is saying
that's wrong that's going to be a
problem so it is sometimes very
important that we need to basically make
sure that our caches have good data
consistency and that in and of itself is
going to take a full video so of course
that means the next videos that we're
going to be looking at are going to be
cash rights and cash eviction policies
so I hope you guys are looking forward
to those because I will be posting them
soon anyways guys have a great night
looking forward to the next ones and
keep slaying